plus fondamentalement ce à quoi vous
avez fait référence c'est c'est la
guerre cognitive c'est là nous disent de
façon très publique les dirigeants de
l'Armée populaire de libération de la
République populaire de Chine c'est là
que se trouve le le théâtre de combat
ultime des nations au 21e siècle à
l'intérieur même du
cerveau de nos concitoyens et c'est la
raison pour laquelle des investissements
considérables sont fait par ces acteurs
notamment par la Chine pour pénétrer
l'esprit de nos concitoyens vous citiez
TikTok bien évidemment qui est une porte
d'entrée à la fois majeure et
particulièrement inquiétante mais il y
en a d'autres un récent rapport publé le
3 septembre me semble-t-il de Microsoft
indique que parmi tous les influenceurs
qui sont financés par le ministère des
Affaires étrangères chinois en Europe
les plus nombreux sont les Français et
qu'en recrutant des influenceurs
français francophones il s'agit aussi
d'achever de réduire l'influence de la
France en Afrique dans l'océan Indien il
y a une entreprise de déstabilisation à
l'égard de notre pays qui est manifeste
et qui est même pas dissimulé les toutes
les doctrines militaires de la Chine de
la Russie sont disponibles en ligne
toutes les adaptations qui sont faites
aujourd'hui par les doctrines militaires
occidentales cell du Pentagone il y a
quelques jours cell de l'OTAN qui est en
train d'être d'évoluer sont également
disponibles et montrent qu'il y a une
prise de conscience mondial de la
gravité inédite de l'intensité inédite
de la menace cognitive chinoise